[Music]
sir the police are here please
detective can we talk about this
I'm gonna pay you for your time
stop he's not a cop this is what my son
does he plays these games all that work
for one thousand dollars
if you're gonna steal
a lot
what are you doing here just wanted to
say hi I had a good time all right cool
see you around dad
I always assumed my son would inherit
all this he doesn't have the fortitude
he's weak
[Music]
you like him a little bit
of course I like him he's a billionaire
we're celebrating what exactly are we
celebrating millions of dollars
roll up your sleeves trust me
you can't cheat on this man
that's why we never feel sorry for the
mark I really like you I really like
kids now you lied to me we're all human
just doing the best we can you cause
your mother anguish
and I will not have it she wants to be
gone
how do you think it says
not well
[Music]
what did you tell him I'm gonna take a
billion dollars and aim it in your
direction
bro
[Music]
it's real
this is real
can I be sure
[Music]